my name's Levi I live in Los Angeles
California
but I'm a ragin Cajun from Lafayette
Louisiana Lafayette is one a giant
welcome party come into our town come
into our city and we're gonna feed you
we're gonna make you feel good and when
you go home you're gonna say that I
can't wait to go back there I'm headed
back to Lafayette I'm gonna meet up with
my best friend from high school growing
up Scott and we're gonna hit three of my
favorite spots called Scott Morgan
calling Scott Morgan oh hey Levi I'm in
the driveway Scott Morgan let's go Levi
how you doing man
looking great there's all this pressure
in high school to get in to either
different cliques or be part of the cool
crowd and I feel like you and I we just
hit it off like we blazed our own path
yes so where you taking me first
we are headed to vermilion ville I have
been taking the tour there in years
vermilion ville is the best-kept secret
in this area it is a place where people
can come walk through history and walk
through time
[Music]
are you gonna bring your kids here uh I
plan to definitely absolutely haven't
yet they're still a little young but I
think that it's important to get them
here and seeing the Cajun culture and
education and all that we're here at the
ferry the only way to get to the other
side it's right here are you ready all
right I don't have a gym membership
anymore this really helps me catch up
and everything I've been missing out on
we are going to pretty John's some Cajun
cooking I'm excited because like well
like I've ever ever get to go there from
breakfast I've never turned out a good
gumbo or good etouffee myself
[Music]
we started off as a little crawfish
boiling room and now we're at gigantic
operation we're known throughout all of
Lafayette and the surrounding area kind
of for being a local up get this catfish
where you going uh-huh
I eat when I come home it's good to
catch up because we don't really get to
do that you know as much as we would
like to I don't think I've seen you
since like you had your son three three
years ago all right time passes quickly
you kind of turn around you realize that
three years is going by I'm done talking
with you I want to eat the safety fake
so where we headed for our final stop
we're gonna head to Avery island jungle
gardens every time I'm in love to walk
around the gardens go with my sisters
and my mom and we we love it out there
it's it's so beautiful this is really
cool just to kind of like revisit our
friendship because it's I think it's the
first time we've really gotten to do
this probably in 15 20 years absolutely
[Music]
what do you think has changed the most I
think for me it's just a different
perspective you look at it differently
than you did as a you know as a child
you should come to appreciate a little
bit more so what does it feel like to be
back here
it feels very familiar like this is I'd
say for like the last 10 years anytime I
come home this is somewhere that can all
spend an entire day here so as we drive
downward by the lagoons or we've seen
the Gators it's like oh yeah like I'm
home right now so they're anything like
this in Los Angeles I don't think
there's really much that looks like this
in LA
[Music]